a couple minutes but let's go ahead and
get started uh we have uh
it's a pleasure to have hulk holger
house speaking today
uh he's at both
leiden and ubc as i understand it that's
correct
um he's a professor of machine learning
enlighten at least according to his
webpage so
that's great um i was also noticed that
i didn't know this before that he is the
author of music notation software
and has done written various things for
music notation so uh
that looks very interesting at any rate
uh it's a pleasure to have him here he's
speaking on cooperative competition a
new way of solving staff and other np
heart problems
in ai and beyond so older
thank you very much sam it's a pleasure
to be here of course in reality like
many of you i would much rather be
uh really in berkeley right uh i
i was very much hoping that would be
possible again in the near future but of
course this event is another virtual one
um so
hopefully uh many of you are not too sad
to hear me speak like this last time i
was uh at the simons institute i had a
great time
um and i was also kind of mortified and
petrified because
i was looking around the audience and
there were three touring award winners
right there in the audience and
that made me aware that that was a
pretty high-stakes talk so today i can't
see you all i have no idea whether
there's any touring award winners here
but i see a few friendly faces which is
very good
i do want to make a big disclaimer
though i mean this institute
that's hosting me today is called
science institute for the theory of
computing
so i hope that what i'm going to tell
you is will be of interest
to people that are intrigued by the
theory of computing and dedicate their
careers to that
but i'm not making any claim that i'm
contributing to the theory of computing
or leveraging the theory of computing at
all
the talk that i'm going to give is is
actually quite empirical and practical
in a sense
but to the extent that theoreticians
sometimes like to be inspired by
practice and look at
you know what their findings might mean
for more practical settings hopefully
you will find something useful here
nevertheless but certainly it's not a
theory talk
so let's talk about competition
this picture here was taking at the
summer olympics in 1956
and you see a very typical situation you
see one guy at the top of the podium
there
he looks mighty happy and then you see a
silver and a bronze model medal winner
and
they look sort of maybe not quite as
happy right
um although certainly they they did well
um
and and so you know competition is
something that uh
we enjoy as entertainment but we
certainly
also value in science as a driving force
uh that
you know compels us to give our very
best right and then when we succeed and
we make the top of the podium we're
happy and
if we just narrowly miss or not so
merrily miss to make the top of the
podium then maybe we are
inspired to work harder next time around
so in sad solving which is what this
workshop is about competitions have
played a very important role for a few
decades now
but not just in sat there are many other
areas in computer science where
you know solver competitions have really
moved the needle have
helped us improve the state of the art
and actually
gain evidence present evidence for these
improvements
so problem-solving competitions are
great aren't they
they assess the state of the art in
solving a problem such as sat so we know
exactly how good we can be and we don't
have to rely
on big o notation or something like that
to tell us which algorithm is better we
can actually run them and see what the
constants are
they do provide incentives for improving
the state of the art right we want to
make the top of the podium so we work
hard
our students work hard they do provide
guidance to practitioners and users of
solvers right if somebody who
isn't an expert in start solving wants
to use a start solver for something
i bet it doesn't take long for them to
find
the sad solver competition pages and
particularly the result pages and that
might inspire them to prefer one solver
over another
but there are problems and the problems
are that the results of such
competitions are often statistically
questionable that the winning solvers
are not always
truly best in class and
as a result neither reflect the true
state of the art
nor do they provide a proper incentive
for improving that state of the art
and those four or three and a half facts
i call the inconvenient truths about
competitions
now don't misunderstand i'm not against
competitions at all but i think it's
very important to recognize
them for what they really are in order
to do
even better than the current setup
allows us typically to do
so i don't ask you to take sort of my
inconvenient truths at face value
i want to convince you at least a little
bit that you know
i do have a point there actually three
and a half points so let's walk through
this quickly
so my first point is about assessing
competition outcomes and the question
there that i want to ask
is how robust are the outcomes of
competition such as sad competitions
to modest changes in the benchmark set
because you see if they weren't robust
to modest changes in the benchmark
set then of course the competition
wouldn't be meaningless but it wouldn't
generalize very well
beyond the narrowly defined setting of
that particular competition and
therefore they would be much less useful
i think we can all agree
then if these findings did generalize if
they were this kind of robustness
and so the idea that a few students of
mine and a colleague
had a while ago was to just to
statistically assess
this is existing competitions
with respect to this question using
resampling methods
and here's what you find so this is the
2014 sat competition so you can
guess we we started doing this a while
ago and what you see here is
on the x-axis the coverage metric
which is the metric that you maximize in
order to win the competition so
lingaling here is the solver that won
the sequential set plus unsattrack that
year right
and then next was this s w d
i a s b y a 26 and so on right
and so you see immediately a bunch of
things so the official competition
results are indicated in red here and
what you see is that
the winner actually had a bit of an edge
but then there were three solvers that
were almost tight
and then it's an incredibly tight field
up to around here
where then all of a sudden you start
getting into stragglers
right but now if you use resampling
to be precise bootstrap resampling you
can actually
create confidence intervals around these
point outcomes of the competitions and
that's what these uh
blue bars are they're 90 confidence
intervals
bootstrap confidence intervals and what
you can see is that these overlapped so
much that we really shouldn't be too
sure that the statistical that the
difference is between
um gold and silver and bronze and
actually the fourth and fifth and sixth
and seventh all the way up to
you know beyond the tenth we should not
have any faith that these are
statistically significant
at all and in fact if you look at how
often
a solver actually wins over 10 000
bootstrap
samples um then or it gets the same rank
then then you get a very clear picture
and that is that lingaling here
it does win in a significant number of
these samples but not even half of them
right and in the middle here these
solvers the ranks that they got in the
official competition are almost
completely arbitrary and not robust
what is actually very stable are the
bottom ranks
right and if you look back that makes
perfect sense because clearly this is
highly significant huh
oliver connects the question yeah of
course yeah so
going back to your uh to your account to
your confidence bands
it does seem like those are bands are
all the same width
is that correct and uh no they are not
yeah i also used to see
all center they also know this one is
actually a little narrower so the fact
that they
all have roughly the same width that's
just an indication that
interestingly enough these solvers sort
of have the same statistical stability
with respect to small permutations
actually resampling of the underlying
benchmark sets
but you can see differences right this
is much narrower than this one here
yeah but but looking at that stack on on
the right there
that's a very close solvers it looks
like the competition
red dot is right in the center of the
band always
is there something going on here that i
don't understand yeah
that just means that um it's it's
actually not plus minus standard
deviation if that's what you mean right
and if you look very closely this for
instance not really in the middle of
that band right
but it turns out that the competition
outcome wasn't atypical right
so it wasn't just luck right but it is
true
actually that you know there are many
better outcomes and many worse outcomes
as well
that's just the way this this cookie
crumbles yeah but it's a good
observation
i think the reason why it's relatively
symmetrical is also because you know we
did take 10 000 samples so it's a pretty
big sample
um in there okay let me go on
um the second point is assessing the
strength of solvers rather than the
degree of tuning right and that is an
argument that has been made by many
people before it goes like this we know
that solver parameters have big
impact on performance and different
values are good for different types of
instances so
when you actually launch a solver in a
competition you can never be
quite sure whether its parameters are
chosen well for that particular
competition right
and so now what you don't want is that a
solver basically
um doesn't make the podium just because
it was unlucky in terms of parameters
where somebody else had a lucky guess in
the parameter and that's
sort of the unfair tuning problem right
so if somebody had
maybe a better idea of what kind of
instances would come up then maybe they
would have tuned themselves a little bit
more to them and again it wouldn't
generalize very much if we looked at
different benchmarks and so the idea
here is to use automatic configuration
so sort of a very uniform and principled
and explicit mechanism
as a key ingredient ingredient of the
competition itself and then
you know if indeed this is a concern
then we will see that if you configure
all solvers using the same computational
resources in the same protocol
you will get very different results but
if it's not as big a deal then maybe you
get the same results as in official
competitions and
we again started uh looking at this in
2013
and ran two competitions called the
configurable sat solver competitions
uh together with some students and and
kevin dayton brown
at ubc we applied automatic
configuration with a uniform protocol
and budget to all submitted solvers
um we had multiple high-performance
configurators even to make sure that we
don't get misled by a configurator
that's particularly effective for
certain solvers and then we ranked based
on the performance
of the configured solvers per instance
set and of course we didn't configure on
the final competition instances but on
some training set right
so here's lingeling once again this is
2013
uh configurable sat solver competition
and what you can see is default
performance of lingeling and and each of
these
markers here is one instance and then
the after configuration that performs
and this time
it's time right for solving the instance
so so lower is better
right and what you can see is that for
many instances there is a speed up
between anywhere between two and a
hundred fold and sometimes even more
than 100 fold that you get by
configuring the solver
and that's lingering that's a solver
that is expert configured to start with
right but just not for these particular
benchmarks
so the average running time on on these
sat encoded software verification
instances so pretty realistic instances
actually drops from 3.32 to 0.60 cpu
seconds
in uh through configuration and uh
it raises from rank four to rank one on
industrial set and unsaid
right so in other words and this is
configuring all the competitors as well
right so it turns out that
that lingeling actually unconfigured
wouldn't have won that track of the
competition
configured it easily wins it that's
interesting to know
and that's not just lingeling here is
clasp a very different
type of sat solver as many of you know
on sat encoded n rooks problem very
different kind of sat instances as well
in the 2014 configurable sat solver
competition
here the part 10 value which is again a
cpu time measurement
uh drops from 705 to 5 cpu seconds and
the rank rises from five to one on
crafted saturn unsaid
right so in other words if you didn't
configure you would have had somebody
else on the podium he
who which arguably deserved a little bit
less to be there
just because they would have made the
podium due to unlucky choices and
default parameters on clasp
in this case the third point is about
leveraging performance complementarity
and this is something that
i should point out you know the workshop
is called 50 years of satisfiability
and one of the things that happened in
these 50 years is not just that we got
amazingly good solvers and lots of
progress there but also
we learned and said actually we learned
this arguably first
in all of computer science that
by actually running more than one solver
you can typically get better performance
or at least considering more than one
solver and examples for these sorts of
techniques are
parallel algorithm portfolios or in
machine learning ensembles
algorithms schedules and pipelines where
you run one after the other
and of course for instance algorithm
selectors sat is sort of famous for that
because that's
um to my best knowledge at least the
first major problem in which it was
shown that it's practical and not just a
theoretically nice idea
this is where you use a feature
extractor to drive a selector that then
um that then selects quickly a given
algorithm a given sat solver
that's supposed to work best on the
instance that you that you actually have
okay so let's just uh and of course we
know that you know these things are very
good for sat solving and in fact they
really do define the state of the art
um rather than individual and monolithic
solvers
and that has been shown in competitions
as well so in summary
to this part competitions have helped us
advance the state of the art in solving
ai problems such as sat but also ai
planning machine learning and so on so
competitions certainly
play an important role however they can
suffer from noise and low statistical
significance and i've shown you examples
for the sad competition here but we've
done the same for machine learning
competitions computer vision
competitions
and found exactly the same phenomenon
they typically involve manual out of
context tuning
which also is a bit of an issue in terms
of generalizability of the observations
and they're mostly focused on single
solvers and broad spectrum performance
which is again not what you might really
care about most when you apply these
things in practice
and as a result of all of these factors
competitions often don't reflect the
true state of the art
right and so they are still a good
incentive for us to do better
with our algorithms but looking at that
and going like this won the competition
that got gold in the sad competition
therefore it truly is the world's best
set solver
that's a tricky judgment call to make
and because they don't reflect the true
state of the art they also typically
don't provide an effective incentive to
improve the true state of the art
and this is where we get to this concept
of cooperative competition
which i think is is actually a very
interesting one
the idea is there in a competition we
have multiple competitors
anyway by by definition right it's a
it's a boring competition if there's
just one competitor and we measure on an
absolute scale in that set right so
competitions thrive from having
a broad field so why don't we always
leverage the strength of
all competitors right rather than just
trying to designate a winner
why don't we switch to the goal of
maximizing
team performance quote unquote
and why don't we reward contribution to
team performance
and this is what we started doing a
couple of years ago in the so-called
sparkle challenges
so here we built a competition platform
that we call
sparkle because it makes everybody
sparkle a little bit more than if you
just have
brown silver and gold and you'll see in
a moment why that is
and solvers are submitted to that
platform and that platform then fully
automatically builds a state of the art
per instance selector based on all the
solvers that have been submitted
um and we then assess the solver
contributions
to the overall performance
of these this
selector based on relative marginal
contribution which is a pretty obvious
concept i'll
talk a little bit more about it later
that that had been used in
some of our earlier work and many other
pieces of literature
also what we found useful and inspiring
to do
is to um to have a concurrent assessment
uh and solver development phase uh
so-called leaderboard phase before the
actual
um you know real run of the competition
and then we give credit for
contributions to selector performance
and that goes to the component solver
authors so that if you make a good
component that
brings the team a lot further that
selector a lot further
uh then you will so this is the
equivalent of going from this
where you know the guy on the top of the
podium has gold and smiles and everybody
else doesn't smile really quite as much
to having a gold medal and cutting it up
and giving everybody a slice of the gold
medal that reflects
the contribution that they made to their
team
everybody together um defining the true
state of the art
so we did this in 2018 as part of the
flock olympic games was
closely coordinated with the sad
competition the 2018 sad competition
and was launched in march 2018 there was
a leaderboard phase over
10 days in april and then final results
about a month later
19 open source servers were submitted
and four closed source or concourse
solvers
this is not much worse than the main sat
competition so a pretty broad field once
again and many of the solvers
were actually solvers that also
participated in the main competition if
you're interested about details
here's a url you can even click it later
when the slides are
online um how did we do this well
of course we needed training and testing
sets right we we can't
actually build the selector based on the
ultimate competition instances that
would
not be proper methodologically so we
constructed a trading set uh consisting
of over a thousand instances from 25
families
all from previous stat competitions and
races as you would do if you wanted to
see how well your solver performs that
you're about to enter into a new
competition
of course you know you tried on old
competition data
and then we had a testing set which was
400 instances from 23 families that was
identical to the testing set of the main
track of the 2018
stat competition and unknown to us
until the end of the leaderboard phase
so even us as competition designers
didn't know that set
and in particular we couldn't have an
informed training set construction and
this will come back
later so we we then split the training
set into a core training set
and a validating set um we did that
basically by randomly selected family
selecting families
and then basically that left us with you
know a slightly larger core training set
and a slightly smaller validation set
based on this we constructed 100 per
instance selectors using auto folio
which i'll say a little bit more in a
moment
that's a per instance selector
construction method from the literature
we trained on the core training set and
we chose the one of the hundred
selectors with the smallest part two
score which is just the official sat
competition score
every time out uh penalized by a factor
of two
um on the validating set right that's
what we use the validating set for
so why autofolio um autofolio actually
is
arguably or was at least at the time the
most powerful
automatic solver selector
building framework it is an
automatically configured one so it
actually has the ability to
search a large space of possible
for instance algorithm selector
construction methods and use the best
for a given context
um it's based on a very well-known
flexible per instance algorithm
selection framework called class folio 2
coming out of the asp literature
and it leverages state-of-the-art
general-purpose algorithm configuration
namely the smart method
that is quite widely used so what it
means is that it's a cutting-edge and
robust algorithm selector
construction method that we've
integrated into the sparkle platform
um how do we act how do we assess solver
contributions
well that merits also a little bit of
thought because that's what we're going
to ultimately reward in our scheme
so given a set of solvers let's call
that set yeah ask a question
yeah this is wanting to to configure
these solvers that are submitted do they
provide an
api to you that you they have to conform
to or do you
actually oh command line parameters and
so on
in here we don't configure solvers
so i should have made this very clear we
configure
the solver selector but the individual
solvers are used exactly as given in the
competition we'll get back to that at
the end
we could configure it but it would make
things a lot more complicated it would
be a good idea by the way
but we didn't do that so we just took
individual solvers as in the normal sat
competition
but we then configured a selector right
so the configuration only happened on
the selector not on the solvers
thanks for asking thank you um okay so
how do we assess server contributions
given a set of solvers and a per
instance selector
based on that set of solvers an instance
set
we define the absolute marginal
contribution which
essentially is the reduction in part 10
score
that you get when you take out a
particular solver
right and because these part 10 scores
are running times we do this in a
multiplicative way
and then we take a log so that we get
nice numbers
okay and so then what we really do is we
normalize that
so that everything sums to one to get
relative marginal contribution so that
way
we can then cut up our gold medal more
easily right so that somebody who gets
15
basically better have a relative
marginal contribution of 0.15
so here's what happened um here we have
the first leaderboard
the last leaderboard the final
performance on training set and the
final performance on testing set which
was never seen before and actually even
unknown to us
organizers back here okay unknown to us
organizers because we took it from the
main track of the sad competition
and these guys knew it but kept it
secret from us
and these are the part two values so so
low scores are good because it means
fast solar performance so
this is the single best solver right so
the very best solver
on the data that we have you can see
there was
a bit of an improvement between the
first and the last leaderboard and then
another improvement on final training
that's because some people
chose to not reveal their solver before
the leaderboard was close
so they never competed in training they
only competed in the actual race
right and then on final testing it was a
lot worse
and that was because the guys who
organized the sad competition
they thought let's challenge these other
guys and make a final testing set that's
a lot harder than anything that has ever
been seen
in the previous competitions and they
did succeed in that you can see that
it's
you know on average these instances are
you know almost twice as hard as
as they were at this point here so now
let's look at the virtual best solver
this is the best solver if you could
you know for every instance pick the one
solver that solves it best
magically somehow right so a perfect
oracle
and so of course this is a lot better
than the single best solver
and you can see that on the last
leaderboard it's even better
on final training it's yet a little bit
better and on final testing it's still
significantly better than the single
best right
and so this is the camp into which we
want to get with
a realistic selector because you know
this would be a perfect selector nobody
knows how to build this
so this is what our sparkle selector
could do very close on the first
leaderboard to the
to the virtual best still pretty close
here
still pretty close here and better than
the single best but
quite a bit worse here how did that
happen well turns out the final testing
set was not just
much harder but also really different in
terms of the types of instances and
therefore of course
the um the selector performance didn't
generalize as well as one would hope
essentially because these instances were
too different but still we're doing
better
we're closing part of the gap right but
now what's very interesting is this this
is standalone versus relative marginal
contribution so standalone
is part two so low bars are good so
these are
here are the winners of the competition
right um
these would be the winners of a
competition of a traditional competition
where you just look at the
at the performance of an individual
solver right
this is the vbs a ton better this is the
uh the sparkle selector and you can see
that you know the difference between
gold silver and bronze is much smaller
than the difference between
that and and these ones here right
so now let's look at the relative
marginal contributions and the shocking
thing is
the best solvers don't have the largest
marginal contributions but
even stragglers have sizeable marginal
contributions right
so in including these guys into a
selector
makes a lot of sense this guy here is a
ton better in standalone performance
than any of these guys here
but including that solver doesn't give
us any advantage completely dominate by
dominated by something else
okay so now let's look on testing set i
told you the testing set is very
different and now you can see
the difference between silver gold and
bronze there not unlike
previous competitions that i've shown
you before is very very small and then
there's a bit of a middle field and
there's a big gap and here's the rest
right
notice what i've shown you before was
the 2014 competition this year is 2018
so four years later qualitatively looks
exactly the same
now the bbs still is a lot better the
sparkle selector is
only a little bit better than the gold
medal winner but look the difference
between this
and the and the difference between gold
and silver is much much larger right so
in other words this one
is is actually significantly better than
those two okay and again on the testing
set you see the marginal
relative contributions over here and by
the way you read this as
a percentage scale here um you can see
that you know it's not the case that the
best solvers contribute the most
to performance so this is interesting
um and just to put it into numbers you
know where the sbs is 4740 the vbs
2710 the sparkle selector actually
closes 14.3
of that hypothetical gap which is not
great but also
really really good especially compared
to how small the gap between gold and
silver is in here
right so here's the official results
from this uh
from our competition which is now
ranking according to marginal
contribution on the testing set
here crypto mini set actually wins and
that is the one that also has standalone
rank one but only very narrowly
but its relative marginal contribution
is only 12.97
so they only get like 13 of the gold
medal
the second one happens to be in this
case also the same but with less than 10
now but now look at the third one this
has a relative marginal contribution
almost as high as the second but it's
ranked only 11th in terms of standalone
contribution
and it continues to go down like this
right and there are also
examples such as this one which is rank
4 in terms of absolute performance and
only rank
six with seven point something percent
uh in terms of the relative marginal
contribution
so now an interesting question is what
would happen if we could train on
instances that are actually from the
same families as our testing instances
which for
practical applications is a lot more
relevant right you use that for solving
software verification
well chances are the instances you're
going to see are
similar to previous software
verification instances rather than
similar to you know whatever n
queens instances right so this
i would argue is a much more realistic
setting so what we now did is we took
the testing set
um of 400 instances from 23 instance
families
and we split that set into 50
50 training and testing set for each
family
right and so then what we get is a very
different result we can now close 55.7
percent of the gap because of course our
testing
instance is now in a proper supervised
machine learning way they are actually
um drawn from the same distribution in a
sense as the training instances right
and it's easier to see this in pictures
so this is what this looks like again
qualitatively very similar on the new
testing set
right this is the the virtual best
solver the perfect oracle
and this here is the sparkle selector
and you can see
now we're actually sort of in the middle
of that gap between
a perfect predictor which unfortunately
we don't know how to make
and no predictor whatsoever just
choosing the best
and notice how big the difference is
between the gold middle
middle winner in a traditional
competition and the real
state-of-the-art performance we get here
this is a difference that's almost as
big as the difference between
sort of you know the end of this winning
field and then the stragglers
and again what you can see is that the
relative marginal contributions are very
different and here you can actually see
a case where
the biggest contribution comes from
actually the last one
in this first leading field but you know
a solver that that would have never even
gotten close to the podium in a
traditional competition
and you can see that even those
stragglers back there jointly
they actually contribute more uh than
the first two together
so this is interesting we were wondering
of course whether this is another case
where you know sat can
sort of trace that can can can
can basically blaze the trail um and we
tried the same for ai planning which is
another domain
in which competitions have a very long
history right so ai planning they've had
competitions as long as the sat
community
actually and they play uh they pay a lot
of
attention to them as well and so here we
choose a setting that's similar to a
very prominent
track of the international planning
competition ipc series called the agile
track i don't want to explain it in
detail but
it is one of the tracks that that people
really like competing in and pay a lot
of attention to
we launched it in june 2018 um actually
sorry
june 2019 that's a typo here with the
leaderboard face this time of four weeks
so we wanted more leaderboard and final
results than at the
icaps conference um 10 open source
planning systems are submitted
and that's because not quite as many
people work on planning
on at least that kind of planning um
then
then on sat again you can find the
details
on the competition website here but just
to
point out some of the difference to our
assad challenge we had a longer
leaderboard phase 30 versus 10 days
we had a stronger notion of instance
families because in planning this comes
naturally they have so-called planning
domains always happens from the
beginning
and a large number of diverse domains
for trading so 52 domains
actually versus 25 percent fewer
competitors because
there's just fewer people who make
state-of-the-art planners and a
different performance metric part 10
versus part 2 because that's what they
like to use
so i'm just going to walk you through
the pictures here so you can see this is
now
just on testing set not not training set
right and you can see that
uh these are the standalone solvers this
is the virtual best the perfect selector
and this is the actual one and you can
see how much of this gap we actually
close so we now close
the major part of this gap and again the
the relative marginal contributions
and here you can see the stragglers
don't contribute but for instance this
number
um this number six over here contributes
actually way more than the number three
solver
so quantitatively very similar to what
we've seen before
and again there's a nice improvement
over time um right so you can see
through the leaderboard
things get better and not just in terms
of standalone performance but also in
terms of the final performance
of our red sparkle selector which are
approximations of this true state of the
art
and the blue lower bounds on the state
of the art
and then you can see that this time this
generalizes very nicely to testing which
is
because there is this uh this widely
accepted and very relevant notion of
instance families
uh and the testing set was was in that
sense more representative of the
training data we had
so we're getting um closer towards the
end of this talk so so let me try to
summarize a bit
um what are the advantages of these
cooperative competitions and by the way
why do i call them cooperative
competitions it's quite clear by now
right
the way you win this competition is not
by being better than anybody else
the way you win this competition is to
basically fill a gap that nobody else
can fill
right so you get the maximum slice of
your gold medal by
making the maximum contribution to team
performance
and that is an inherently cooperative
act right you're still competing
but you're competing by maximally
increasing team performance and
therefore
your improvement is actually relative to
everybody else right if you change the
team members then your contributions
will also change
and so the advantages of this is first
of all it makes it easier to gain
recognition for specialized or niche
techniques right that could never win a
combination competition um
old style right um and this is as much
as you know if if you have a football
team
and and everybody is is a great you know
forward player
that will be not a good team right
because for instance you also need a
good goalie but if you have a team
that's just goalies they will also not
do well right and it's essentially the
same here right here you can shine by
being a good goalie um
this also better reflects and makes
accessible the state of the art so
if somebody looks at a sparkle challenge
and says you know give me the state of
the art we can't because what it is
it's the sparkle selector right now this
isn't to say that you couldn't
potentially make something even better
for instance if somebody comes up with a
better method for building selectors
based on given solvers
but certainly it's much closer to the
true state of the art
than is a single best solver as i've
demonstrated
it also leverages synergy
complementarity and these
meta-algorithmic design techniques that
have been pioneered to a certain extent
in sat and what i mean by
meta-algorithmic design techniques is
specifically algorithm selection here
and secondarily algorithm configuration
as used to make the best
selector in this case right but now are
being used basically everywhere
and finally because this captures better
more accurately although not perfectly
the true state of the art it also
provides a better incentive to improve
the true state of the art because the
true state of the art is
a team performance not a solo
performance
there are some further benefits um
a setting like that makes automatic
solver construction much more accessible
than it would be otherwise the people
who submitted solvers to our competition
didn't need to know
the slightest thing about how to run a
to run auto folio they didn't know how
to make
a per instance selector right we did
that for them in a completely
transparent way
it also promotes and ensures best
practices in the use and evaluation
of of such techniques and it gives you
improved reproducibility and it does
that
because you know the selector is not
some handcrafted thing it is
it is built by the algorithm right so
you can look deep inside and understand
precisely what's happening there
so what's next we're not done here and
actually sam was very very
um quick in picking up on something we
haven't done yet
which is we use automatic configuration
but we don't apply it where we really
should namely to the individual solvers
we did that in the cssc series
but we didn't do it here because there
are some challenges associated with that
not just in terms of requiring more time
in terms of running the competition but
also in terms of
you know making the configurator and as
accessible as we currently make the
selector
uh to competitors of course we could
extend this to parallel portfolios which
would probably be a wise thing given
that if you really wanted to do sad
solving and practice and
you know wall clock time matters you
know real world time matters
you would of course run more than one
solver in parallel
and maybe we should also look at
optimization of solution quality
so we can apply this to problems such as
scheduling problems and machine learning
problems where
running time isn't typically the thing
that you're most concerned about
also there is still an issue we assess
contributions in a pretty reasonable way
but
if you think about it carefully it's not
perfect right because for example
if you insidiously submit the same
solver twice
but mask that so that it's not obvious
that you have two copies of the
same solver both of them will get
relative marginal contribution
zero right in other words you can wreck
somebody's success in the competition by
copying their solver and submitting it
now in reality we've watched out for
that and you know with 10 or 19
submissions you can
and there is telltale signs that
something like this happens but
it would be nice to automatically
recognize and deal with adversarial
behind behavior and there is a little
bit of a sort of
you know applied game theory um
challenge here and then finally and
from my perspective perhaps most excited
exciting the um it would be nice to have
mechanisms for deeper collaboration to
go from cooperative competition
to what i would call competitive
cooperation and one way of doing that
would be to say well you know
maybe sam has a good solver and i have a
good solver and we've already
found enlightenment in feeling that we
shouldn't sort of just
force anyone to pick his or mine but we
should you know have a per instance
selector that tells people
for this instance use sams and for this
instance use mine right
but maybe it would be even nicer if
somebody else like say
stefan here could take sam solver
and my silver and tweak it a little bit
and make the make his own variants
right now i would love that but of
course if if those then make big
contributions i'd like to be
acknowledged somehow right
and mechanisms that allow that right
that allows sort of
sharing and reuse of components and give
fair credit for that would
would fit very nicely into the context
of this overall
um intellectual effort that i'm
describing here and then of course from
a purely pragmatic point of view um it
would be nice
to have further sparkle challenges um
especially after we've
after we've uh realized some of these
extensions that we're currently working
on and and we are indeed
pretty close to finishing the first of
these we're working hard on the second
um the third we haven't paid too much
attention to but it's also i think not
that hard
and and and these ones we are we've
started to think about
pretty deeply so let me wrap up
in a nutshell competition is useful in
sat in ai
and elsewhere right competition makes us
give our very best when we want to solve
a problem and and that's useful
but success um in competitions as in the
real world should actually depend on
teamwork
and we know that because the best
solvers are typically not built by a
single person but by a team of
scientists you know
most impactful papers are not written by
a single author but by a team of authors
and are better for it
so why in a competition should we have a
single solver that
that is winning gold right so that's why
i think we should go to cooperative
competition where
we compete for contribution to team
performance where everybody does well by
having the team do
maximally better this is enabled by meta
algorithmic design techniques such as
automatic configuration and automatic
selection which have to a large degree
being pioneered or at least
developed in inset
and now are being made accessible
broadly in the sparkle platform that my
group is developing
um and finally i also think that you
know taking this perspective we
we better leverage human creativity and
diversity of perspective
and also the complementarity of
individual solutions to challenging
problems and you know
that's pretty important because uh this
morning when i woke up i saw that spacex
had just
managed to for the first time not only
land their
starship prototype but also not have it
explode a few minutes later
so i think it's pretty difficult for us
to
to overestimate the impact of
of that right because fully reusable
access
to space uh will really be a game
changer and and possibly as elon musk
likes to say even a game changer for the
species but let's not kill ourselves
right
this planet that we're looking on here
actually straight down to the north pole
and is the most habitable and and and
the best place that we know of
in the universe and certainly the the
most uh the best one accessible to us so
we better take good care of it
and and to do that we have to protect
things like this right which which
actually is the arctic ice cap
right and that thing is shrinking and
that's not good for us
um and so it is in this sense that i
think in computer science and beyond we
should really pay close attention to
what alan turing already said as early
as 1948
the search for new techniques must be
regarded as carried out by the human
community as a whole
and in that sense you know really it's
about high time to switch from all out
individual competition
to cooperative competition in science as
much as in our other
endeavors thank you very much that is
the end of my presentation
i think that should leave us with quite
a bit of time for questions
thank you very much that was a very nice
talk and very stimulating and
you know i appreciate the comments on on
the earth at the end as well
very very nice theme um we have plenty
time for questions
i have a list of my own but they're
already starting to stack up in the q a
window
so we'll go to those first and see what
we have time for i encourage everyone
else to
post questions to either the chat window
or the q a window so the first one
is from fleet bar tech uh can you can
you see this over but i'll read it
anyway
yes i can actually see it so he asks
have you considered using contribution
measures other than quote
relative marginal contribution unquote
what are their advantages and
disadvantages
so the answer is uh we have actually
kevin leighton brown
myself and students that we jointly work
with have considered
sharply value which is a well-known
concept from cooperative game theory
and a variation of it that we introduced
called temporal sharply value that sort
of
pays a little bit of attention to
precedent uh
you know the solvers that were there
before others came
um and it would doubtlessly be good to
use
and to sort of you know cut up the gold
medal based on on these because they
address some of the issues that are
pointed out with respect to you you know
for instance masking the contribution of
others
the problem is these become
computationally very expensive
and so in sparkle we didn't implement
that yet because we couldn't find out a
way to uh
compute this reasonably accurately
within reasonable time but but certainly
it's something we're exploring and i do
think that
a better way of assessing contributions
than relative marginal contribution
um is a very nice improvement to our
overall framework so i agree with you
philip
that that would be good to do
good matthias asks
uh matisse flory when are solvers
dissimilar enough to avoid the
adversarial problem
are solvers from hack track dissimilar
enough
that is a fascinating question i like
particularly the second part of the
question right because
it is something that i've always wanted
to look at and we haven't done it yet so
um
matthias unfortunately i don't have the
answer for you yet but uh
you know realistically i should just
tell one of my students to to run that
experiment
um my suspicion is um you know some of
the solvers that
uh we dealt with here uh that that form
this tightly packed
field let me actually go back to to
ground this a little bit in
in in figures here um
you know as as many of us in in sat
solving know
um many of these solvers here are
actually not
that dissimilar right so so there many
of them are based
on the same underlying ideas right um
and so what you can see is that
certainly for them
this masking problem doesn't seem to be
too harsh
right it's difficult to tell it just
from this figure but but at the very
least
you know things like this could be
potentially knocked out because of this
but then you look at solvers that are
very closely related to these and you
see that they actually
um do get a very very sizable
relative marginal contribution so based
on that i suspect
that even in the hack track it's not a
huge
issue but it bothers me
not because this adversarial setting i
think distorts our results
but more because i think you know in
part here you see me arguing that
a traditional competition gives us the
wrong incentives
and this competition still gives an
incentive that's sort of manipulable
a little bit too easily right even if
the manipulation doesn't happen and
isn't
isn't likely to happen perhaps
accidentally or in something like the
hack track
the fact that it's possible really
bothers me so i do think that
um you know first of all we should have
a better answer then i currently can
give you my tears to your
question number one and two and and
secondly
um we should really find a mechanism
that uh
that makes this question redundant where
we where we know that the incentives are
right and that we're
protected against adversarial attack
ah yes and here's armen with a long
comment this is interesting
yes i've seen that i mean um
let me just summarize it it's too long
to read i'll just say
armin is talking about sub sampling and
they're
uh in their paper from 2000
in pods 19 i believe it was uh showed
that ranking is stable
uh relative to sub to
to sub sampling but i'll let you take
the rest of that over
okay yeah armin and i have a friendly
collegial disagreement about
that so um just as armin doesn't trust
our results too too much i don't trust
his results here or their results too
too much
i think we need to to look a little bit
more deeply into this and what's really
happening here but
i would be i think it's probably an
artifact of the way stability is
assessed in this work versus ours
um what i what i would suspect is that
in in reality um there are situations
where where stability exists right and i
mean
i have to tell you honestly of all the
competitions we looked at it's a little
bit beyond the scope of this talk but
let me go back to this figure
of all the competitions that we looked
at in terms of stability
the sad competition is the worst
in particular that competition that i
was uh
talking about here let me just find the
picture
that competition here um was perhaps
particularly bad right
on the other hand what you have seen
that this extremely close field here it
happened again in 2018
um and that is what armin is referring
to here and
so therefore i would be extremely
extremely surprised
if you had statistical stability in the
rankings that's much better than here
just given how close
um the performance is in the 2018
standalone competition
um again right and so what what i would
say is
that um yeah probably by teasing out
from the benchmark set by by having a
benchmark set that sort of avoids this
which other competitions have managed
better than at least some sad
competitions in the in the past you
avoid this phenomenon but
regardless the most important message is
not did this happen in this competition
and did it again happen or not in 2018
the most important thing is that before
the work that armin mentioned here and
the work that we did
actually before that likely inspires
some of this
um it is an issue right the stability of
competition results
needs to be actually evaluated and then
if we find that it's stable and we can
trust the results that's great and if we
find it's unstable and we can't trust it
we've learned something useful too but
it's simply not acceptable
to just assume that it's um that that
it's stable and then not
not study it right and in that sense
then the work that armin mentions
and ours both make the same important
point and that is
it's important to assess the statistical
stability of competition
outcomes and sometimes it's stable and
sometimes it's it's less so
okay um
well armin's not a panelist i could
promote him if he wishes but uh
he can also type back and answer if he
wishes why don't we move on though
we come back to this issue as people
raise it um
paul b asked a question in the chat
window paul do you want to speak up or i
can read it for you
um let me go ahead and read it so one of
the items that the usual sat solvers are
measured on in the sac competition
is the number of unique instances solved
do you have comparisons with that and
relative marginal contributions
is that where much of the benefit of low
performing solvers is coming from
yeah that's that's a very insightful
comment um so
you know all these studies this one here
um and also what we did later
we didn't use this although i agree with
with paul that um you know this is a
better measure the unique the um
instances right however what we wanted
to do is we wanted to compare this with
the competition as it stands today
and really uniquely solved is not the
way gold silver and bronze are
adjudicated right
having said this i think uniquely solved
is in some sense
hmm it is in a similar way perhaps
um giving you an impression of of how
large the the relative marginal
contribution ought to be or could be
as the bbs tells you with respect to
how good a selector could be however
i i firmly believe that you know if if
you want to
assess contribution to team performance
why do it in such a roundabout way right
even if it you end up capturing some of
the same things why not capture the
thing that you really
care about which is not uniquely solved
instances it is contribution to team
performance right
and absolutely somebody who has a large
swath of uniquely solved instances
should be expected to to contribute more
um
right probably in a formalizable way
that should give us a bound on relative
marginal contribution
um but why not measure the real thing
right now what i find interesting about
paul's question is and this is maybe a
question that
a theoretician could answer on the spot
and and i unfortunately can't although i
have my suspicions
maybe you legally solved instances in a
very crisp and precise sense
does give us a bound on relative
marginal contribution
at least to a perfect selector i think
that's quite possible
and if it does then of course you know
maybe it deserves to be shown in these
plots
so paul if you can see immediately how
this is done i'd be very curious
and otherwise i'll take it away after
this talk and give it a little bit of
thought
okay uh next question was from
uh ciaran recreation sorry if i'm just
pronouncing the name
um has a a practical suggestion to make
this
be more widely usable but uh they write
maybe this work could be used for a
website that lets people upload a few of
their instances and be told
quote if you want one solver use x
configured as y if you want more do dot
dot dot
so that mod experts don't just pick the
competition winner with the default
configuration
yeah i think that's that's a very nice
idea and in fact we're currently writing
a paper about sparkle and cooperative
competition so we hope that this will
make it into a special issue on
benchmarking of a journal that's
interestingly enough in the area of
evolutionary computation but that's
another area that not unlike that is
full of people
who take benchmarking pretty seriously
uh and have reasonably high standards
uh so we're gonna put it there just
because that's the next deadline that
comes up that that we feel is suitable
for this kind of work
um and they're actually an idea that's
not so dissimilar from this uh
will turn up although i i do like uh
karen's idea and that um you know is
even a little bit uh different from what
we had in mind there so yeah
that's uh that sounds like like really
interesting
by the way i should say for all these
questions a chance to do follow-up
questions i don't mean to just pick them
off one at a time but
in the in the lieu of anyone speaking up
more
i'll just keep going through the
questions massey malaria asks uh
is it an issue that sat is a very quote
low level
unquote problem wouldn't the cooperative
approach be more effective in setting
that leverage leverage problem
formulation
in a higher level language i.e before
encoding the cnf
what is your experience so that's
exactly why
uh the second sparkle challenge was on
ai planning right
because i i mean i tell you honestly the
reason we went to sap
first is because it's a community in
which um
my team and i had a lot of experience
with competitions because
you know i've i've you know we've we had
submitted individual solvers and we've
configured solvers and we had submitted
selectors
so we knew a lot about that competition
series and it's always nice to try new
ideas sort of you know with your own
community
but when it worked there the obvious
question was wouldn't it work even
better
in something that hides less of the
structure of the problem that we're
solving because
these 25 families of problem instances
many of them are highly structured
instances as you all know right
and so it's it's you know it's an
insightful question that is being asked
here
what if we can exploit the structure
more um more explicitly and ai planning
is one of these areas where people have
encoded into set and solved as that
and actually gotten very good traction
but then you know there are still people
who write
planners and for a good reason because
the planners can be even better in many
cases
and what we found and that's exactly why
i presented these results to data i
would expect similar results for other
sort of richer domains like qbf
and smt and you know asp and where we
haven't run that yet
but i think it would be very similar i
think you will get
qualitatively very similar results um
but but even better
and it will be even better because in
the sad competition
um you have this this notion that yes
families exist
but but ultimately nobody is taking care
that um
you have the supervised learning
scenario proper in that you know
ultimately the instances that that you
put as a challenge
um can make a reasonable claim of being
drawn from the same distribution as the
training instances and that really is
different in the planning community and
it's different in many other communities
where
the recognition that there's different
types of instances and they're very
different and you shouldn't
sort of really mix them together quite
as readily as we do in sat
is is much more developed so yes i agree
that
um this is even better for uh
problems where the structure is is more
explicit than it
is in sat at least in cnf set
um i missed a question from the q a
window earlier uh zod sawaf asked how is
rmc relative marginal contribution
defined
yeah i apologize i went over this slide
pretty quickly but
you know here it is so what it is is
absolute marginal contribution and that
is just think of that as the performance
difference the only reason it's the log
of um
of uh of this ratio here is because
uh running times sort of more natural we
live on on a log scale
and and what we're dealing with here is
running times these price scores right
so it's really the difference in
performance that you get the hit in
performance that you get
when you knock out one solver right
um and then you normalize this so that
basically your gold medal pieces add up
to a full gold medal
right that's what relative marginal
contribution is so
i apologize for the math on this slide
but uh there's not much behind it
actually it's it's really just the
relative drop in performance as you
knock out
each individual team player right
i hope so yet that uh clarifies things a
bit
so this would mean you get credit for
only if you're the best solver on a
particular
in input instance right
if someone is always the second no not
quite i mean this this
this is why i very carefully answered to
powell earlier right um
the thing is the selector isn't perfect
right
um we we want to deliberately capture
an attainable state of the art not just
give a bound right
and that means we have a real algorithm
selector and that means that even if
you're not the best on any
instance the selector might still choose
you because
in a machine learning sense in a
supervised machine learning sense you
might be a safer bet
than the guy who really is the best or
you just lack the features to
to you know figure out in advance the
guy who's really best
you see what i'm seeing what i'm saying
sam does that make sense yes it does yes
absolutely critically yeah and just i
won't
just for the benefit of people who are
maybe not seeing the chat window there
is
a reference in the chat window from
philip bartek
to paper of holgers on finding these
things
very good yeah indeed and and again i
apologize i went over this a little
quickly so so thank you very much uh
philip um it is exactly uh the paper
actually it's not the paper that i'm
referencing here it's another paper but
i think there must be two papers where
we um
where we introduce this so could find
and uh let's see uh karen
mccreesh has a another comment quote now
the grumpy question
as a solver author i frequently get
annoyed by configurators and portfolios
because they produce really good results
and won't tell me why
so i don't get any clues on how to
design even better solvers
explainable ml is allegedly a thing now
does it work for algorithm selection
um okay let me push back a little bit on
that so
first of all let me say it's true that
currently a lot of meta-algorithmic
techniques are black box but
you know we can probably do better um
you know there's now an increasing
emphasis on explainable machine learning
of course we could restrict ourselves to
machine learning models at the heart of
the selector that are explainable right
we could use decision trees rather than
random force and we could use very small
decision trees and boom
the choice of selector or the choice of
algorithm made by the selector all of a
sudden would be explainable
and i think that would be an interesting
thing to do right for configuration you
can do similar things for configuration
actually there are approaches have been
out for a few
years now that are called parameter
importance analysis techniques
um and they allow you to basically
assess the impact of particular
parameters
to the configuration success so to speak
right i'm a particular fan of something
called
ablation uh that that is inspired by
ablation methods that have been used
in the experimental sciences um where
you basically sort of isolate the impact
of individual factors not unlike you
isolate the impact of
individual solvers here in terms of rmc
actually
quite similar and so i i wouldn't say
that these things necessarily must be
black boxes but but it's true you know
um whenever you bring heuristic
techniques uh
to the table to solve an np-hard problem
in practice
you end up with algorithms that are not
fully comprehensible to us in in the
sense of
why do they work well when they do right
that's the very nature of a heuristic
algorithm at least from my perspective
and i also think philosophically
speaking it's the nature of our current
understanding of np-hardness
right so in some sense i would push back
also in saying to you even if you built
the sat solver from scratch
you don't really understand that solver
either right because it's full of
heuristics and yes you've experimented
with them but they will never cease to
surprise you
and here i would actually challenge
armin to
to contradict me and maybe tell me that
he understands exactly when lingaling
does well and when it doesn't
but i have a feeling that even he will
admit that occasionally his own
algorithms surprise him
as they tend to when we you know solve
np heart problems
so you know once again summarizing um
whenever we deal with np-hard problems
such as that i think our solvers tend to
surprise us and are not fully
explainable and
that shouldn't lead us to lean back and
make them even more opaque but
we should acknowledge that maybe we
can't fully understand and comprehend
and
explain them and secondly the
meta-algorithmic techniques if we
just use them indiscriminately can make
things more opaque but there's no reason
why we shouldn't aim for doing something
better and
actually making them help us understand
and so the final little comment sorry
this is a little long-winded but i think
it's actually
uh maybe interesting um my final comment
is this if we look at results such as
this one here give me a second
i would actually argue a very natural
next step is to look at
you know which are the instances on
which this solver here actually does
well and that gets very close to
powell's comment early you know let's
look at the uniquely
the the the instances that are uniquely
solved by the solver or that are best
solved by that solver or
for which the solver is better than you
know is amongst the top three
and and that might tell us something
about the solver in the instances and
actually give us
more insight than if we just run this by
itself right
and so from that perspective i think we
can turn this around and also saying
this sort of
ensemble view uh can help us understand
a little bit better
which technique works well when and
that's at the heart of understanding our
solvers better
yeah you mostly thank you for the answer
you mostly answered a question i was
going to ask
but let me ask it anyway but you don't
maybe have to answer it again
is it seems to me you could use this
analysis to cluster your solvers
according to
these solvers do well on the same types
of problems
and maybe you could understand somewhat
better the attack the taxonomy of
solvers and their performance and maybe
understand
what what contributes to the success of
a solver
um yes just by looking which solvers are
similar to each other
and which ones duplicate each other and
so forth
so now you get a very short answer and
it is yes you're right
let me just add one sentence to it which
is that
you know we have started doing that not
in this setting but closely related to
it with our work on temporal shapley
values
that we published a few years ago where
we take a more detailed look and a more
sophisticated look at solver
contributions but not in this
competitive setting
and we do that not just for sat but also
for you know even better understood so
for algorithms that we truly understand
a lot better like sorting algorithms
right
and there we see this relationships
these relationships between
algorithms that come out of this
temporal sharply value analysis which is
quite fascinating
and that doesn't go all the way down to
what you're suggesting but but
it follows the same intuition so you're
absolutely right
thank you all right uh last call for
questions or comments um
if there's nothing else we'll uh
wrap things up thank you again for a
very nice talk
and stimulating discussion and lots of
questions and uh comments
and there's a for those of you there's a
a
link to the gather town website that
people would like to go
talk a little more informally afterwards
online it's in the chat window and i
believe this is open
to anyone who clicks on that link is
that right antonina
it's not just specific to simon's
participants anyway
you can quickly find out the workshop
and or simon's participant
uh so workshop or simon's participants
okay so
you're welcome to come uh gather a
little bit of gather dot town
on the link in the chat window so thank
you again i'll clap on behalf of
everybody
and thank you for having me by the way
in case you wonder what the little thing
down here is that's the complexity
monster that's the little guy that we're
fighting when we're solving sam
just in case you wondered so we're
having fun with them
dude okay very good
bye